did you know that most builders have an  exclusion clause at the end of their  contract that basically says we are not  going to supply these items in the  contract so make sure that you check the  end of your contract to know what is  going to be missing when they hand over  the keys  for example curtains and carpets are not  normally included in any contract that  means you have to go out and spend heaps  more money putting in new carpets  putting in new curtains to actually be  able to finish off your house perfectly  and one of the biggest things that is  usually excluded from every single  building contract unless you  specifically ask for it or specifically  nominate it is landscaping and fencing  so if you want some really nice  landscaping or architectural landscaping  design make sure you go see a  professional make sure you speak to  somebody get the plan get the design get  it priced and included in your building  contract